>> So to give this answer, David again uses background knowledge.
Someone else in the class might say that, well, he does not think that
this particular wedge here is the same kind of block as the brick. And
therefore this is not an example of foo. So I want to draw a number of
lessons from this particular exercise. First, learning is often incremental.
We learn from one example at a time. Cognitive agents, human beings,
intelligent agents in general, are not always given hundreds or thousands or
millions of examples right from the beginning. We get one example at a time.
Second, often the examples that we get, are labeled.
There is a teacher which tells us this a positive example, or this is a negative
example. This is called supervised learning in machine learning literature.
Because here there is a teacher which has labeled all the examples for
you. Third, the examples can come in a particular order.
There are always some positive examples, always some negative examples.
The first example, typically is a positive example. Fourth,
this is quite different from case based reasoning. In case based reasoning,
which we had discussed last time, we had all of these examples, which we
stored in their raw form in memory. We'll reuse them. I this particular case,
however, we're abstracting concepts from there. Fifth, the number
of examples from which we're extracting concepts is very small. We're not
talking here about millions of examples from which we're doing the abstraction.
Sixth, when we are trying to abstract concepts from examples, then,
what exactly to abstract? What exactly, to learn? What exactly to generalize,
becomes a very hard problem. There is a tendency to often overgeneralize, or
often, to overspecialize. How does the intelligent agent find out,
exactly what is [UNKNOWN] generalization? These are hard questions, and
we'll look at some of these questions in just a minute.